rictus it has been a bit of a wake-up
call I see a lot of French companies
they have coming to the UK to see how to
set a business knowing that they would
be breaks it and British company are
trying to expand their business in in
the EU so maybe there will be jobs going
to Paris or Brussels which is good for
at least for us but I would say in
general it's quite good so the whole
breadth set backdrop then is really
quite a positive feeling I mean at the
moment I'm not sure in the long term I
don't we can't see any downside to it
I still think in the long run it's it
will limit the rate of growth but at the
moment it's because obviously there's a
lot of talk about in the event of a
heart brexit you could see planes
grounded and not being able to fly I
mean presumably that that really would
put business your way you know I mean
sincerely I hope it won't be the case
for the airlines because I think it will
be bad for the economy bad for everybody
and in general all I'd rather have a
transport sector which goes well in all
in all its moods but you know what we
see that people are really keen to take
the train because you can work on the
train they enjoy in turn actually you
know we want to expand our network build
Paris and ourselves to the Netherlands
just because of that and in terms of
tourist travel that's obviously doing
particularly well as well I think you're
saying there's a lot more Americans
using Eurostar right now is that just a
currency phenomenon yeah it's a mixture
the currency is a big drive for them
because makes a trip to Europe a lot
cheaper but I think also Europe is is a
very good destination and we see that
all the European countries like France
the UK Netherlands Belgium especially
because that's our market they are
spending more money advertising and we
do too on the US market South America
South Korea
I don't know Japan China to attract
those travelers so it's a combination of
her everything
how's the new route standard Leon being
going was that very successful for you
during the summer they love them too
Leon route
oh yeah during the summer it's beautiful
it's doing very well all the way down to
Marseille yeah so we keep doing that and
we see that yeah there is an interesting
the taking the train rather than going
to crowded Airport during the summer so
we are surfing on that and any news on
when the Amsterdam Rouge is going to
open
springtime we're still negotiating I
mean though the governments have to
negotiate the four countries so
Netherlands Belgium France and UK have
to find the right legal framework to
allow the trains to you know the
passport controls it's there so but I'm
confident it will be launched in the
spring time next year it must be quite
tempting given the kind of growth that
you're saying to really push up for
ticket prices yes I know it's still a
very competitive environment against
low-cost airlines that can be can be
there are some casualties
all across Europe because of that it's
very very competitive so our pricing is
linked to what is the prevalent pricing
of the low-cost airlines in Europe in
general so know we are really under
pressure there